>> Welcome Susan.
It's really fabulous to have you
here with us at
Microsoft Research.
Of course, Microsoft is
almost a home for
you in some ways.
>> That's right. It's
great to be here.
>>Yeah. You were
our Chief Economist,
what years was that?
>> Well, so, I
started in 2007 and I
think they endowed me with
that fancy title in early-
>> It's a great title.
>> -2008 and really there
hadn't been a Chief Economist.
So, they decided to create one.
Now, I describe it as
Consulting Chief Economist
because I had
a mix of full-time
as a VR for a while,
and then part-time.
I did that for about seven years.
>> Just so folks out
there know what a VR is,
Visiting Researcher ship.
It used to be VR.
>> Exactly. So,
Microsoft Research has
this great program where without
resigning in your
university position,
you can basically be
full-time at Microsoft.
So, I had a home in
Microsoft Research,
but was also doing
spending a lot of
time with the business as well.
>> Jumping way back in time,
not that far back to
your early college years.
I'm just curious because
a lot of the folks
that come in and watch
these Fireside Chats are
very interested in careers
and mentorship and folks who
inspired folks to do what
they now do in the world.
I'm curious about your own
education and experience.
You are at Duke and
it seemed you were so excited
about so many things.
You had multiple majors.
So, what went on in
your early days of college,
in terms of your thinking about
career and topics of interest?
>> Sure. So, I
actually started in
computer science and I had
gotten a little bit
of exposure to
computer science as a summer job,
selling computers
to the government,
the summer before college.
So, I decided I wanted to
do computer science
and I just took
a few economics classes because I
thought maybe I would
go to a startup.
Of course going to a startup
in the late 80's wasn't really
the trendy thing to do but
it seemed intriguing to me.
Then, I learned about
economics and I actually
had a professor in
economics who picked me out to be
his research assistant
and I actually
started administering
his workstation.
He said, "Oh, I'd love it,
if you got a PhD in economics."
I said. "Well, I don't
really think I'm going to-"
>>This is as undergraduate.
>> As an undergraduate. Yeah.
>> Administering his workstation
and it happened as mentioned his-
>> Well-
>> Impassing.
>> He was really looking to
mentor students to go on
to get PhDs' and he'd had
a number of wonderful
undergraduates.
Actually, it's a nice thing
about being at
a program that has
a good PhD program,
but not a great PhD program
because at Duke,
the undergraduates
were a little stronger
on average than the PhD students.
So, he had been
recruiting undergraduate
research assistant.
>> That's interesting.
What was his name?
>> Bob Marshall.
>> So, did you view him as
an inspiring force in your life
at that point or bridging to?
>> - at first I just
liked to administering
a Unix workstation better
than washing test tubes,
which was my next best
work study alternative
to pay for my school.
But then, over time, I
actually got very
excited about economics.
At the time, computer science
was maybe a little bit more
theoretical and abstract.
So I loved it. But I also,
it was a little bit harder to see
the mapping beyond programming,
the mapping from really
the research side
of computer science
to things that were
more practical and
it sounds crazy now,
because of course,
computer science
is applied everywhere.
But in economics, I felt
a little bit more of
a natural way to see
how the research would
have changed the world.
So, I liked the impact
of economics and I
actually worked on
a bunch of policy
problems with this professor.
He really showed me how research,
he end up testifying before
Congress on something I worked
with him on and so I
got excited about that.
But I never lost my love
of computer science,
so I finished
the computer science major
and the economics major.
The math major came along
the way because I had taken
a pre-theoretical computer
science approach and I
also needed a good math to get
into the best PhD programs.
But then, I went into
the economic direction
and studied auctions,
but I never lost that love
of computer science.
So, it was then,
as I got further in my career,
that these things came back
together in really
interesting ways.
>> To shifting to topical,
it seems there's a thread of
fascination that you've had
with action or decisions under
uncertainty and grappling with
uncertainty in the world,
and looking at economics through
that lens of action
decision making.
You've any comments
about this idea,
of this passion or interest
in uncertainty, in probability?
>> I actually, I would
say that generally
my interest in theoretical issues
has always been as
a means to an end.
So, early in my career,
I was interested in
studying problems about
auctions and mechanism
design and then
there were some technical issues
that needed to be solved to
really make that
theory beautiful.
So, in some ways,
it was a little bit
unnatural for me because
I got more theoretical and
I became very well known
for very theoretical work.
I loved doing it and
it was beautiful,
but actually it wasn't
my main motivation.
My main motivation was to
solve these slightly
more applied problems,
as a means to an end.
So, I think the class of
problems I was interested in
were games under uncertainty,
auctions and mechanisms,
and really designing markets,
trying to figure out
how you can design
institutions or rules
of games to make
them work better and
work more efficiently.
>> But it seem that
the real world but
the uncertainty as
the critical factor
and tell us the reason
about in some ways.
>> In theory of auctions,
the ideas that
the mechanism designer,
the auctioneer doesn't have
all the information
about how valuable
an object is to the participants.
So part of the role
of the auction is to
get that information elicited and
then use it to make
efficient decisions.
But the nature of the game can
lead to efficiency or
inefficiency and how
the bidders respond to
that uncertainty as well as how
the auction design elicits
behavior can make a difference.
So just one application of that,
we looked at for example
the difference between,
for timber auctions,
the difference between having
an open ascending
auction where people
raised their hands and till
the auction ends so
that everybody drops
out versus the first price
seal bid auction where you
send in sealed bids and then
the winner is the highest bidder
and they pay their bid.
So, under some conditions there's
a beautiful theory that says that
those are actually equivalent.
But then under
real world conditions,
there's a bunch of
reasons they're not
equivalent and in particular,
the ones where you have
sealed bids are inefficient.
That is a weaker bidder can win.
It's basically these people
shade their beards and
weaker bidders are
more aggressive bidders and they
can outbid someone
who thinks they're
likely to win and doesn't think
they need to be so aggressive.
So that seems like that's bad
and so you shouldn't
do that but it has
this extra benefit in that it
induces more participation
of weak bidders.
So the bidder's understanding
that they have
a chance to sneak in,
and when and efficiently are
more likely to participate,
and that in turn can fight
collusion and lead to
more competitive auctions.
So I did a lot of
research about that
theoretically and
also working with
data from real timber
auctions to illustrate
the magnitudes of
those effects and
those types of themes
that the rules of
the game have
these direct consequences,
but also this broader
implications for how competitive
a market is and who even
participates in the market
is a theme that then
I brought later to,
say, the advertising options
that the search engine
in Microsoft.
>> That was really exciting to
identify one or more
pathologies and occur in
understanding and or
current implemented
mechanism that lead
to things like
collusion having big effects and
coming up with a new
clean beautiful theory
that addresses
some open world issues
that then give
you a new more bullet
proof mechanism.
Must be a feel good to
have it take effect.
>> Yes. I think
one thing that I think
economics really
trains you well for
is trying to get a model with
just the right amount of
abstraction, that it can
capture the important
forces in the world.
Then, the model is also specific
enough that it makes
sharp predictions
and it can be hopefully
taken the data
and some economic models
really flunk that.
They're too complicated,
they are too
unrealistic and you just
don't fit the data.
But in mechanism design
and auctions has been
a real success of being able
to build the theory
that's actually
useful and then calibrate
it with data and
make predictions.
So one of the things that
we did in the work on
the two different
types of auctions
is we estimated the model,
trained the model using
just the data from
the sealed bid auctions,
the the first price
still bit auctions.
So we calibrated those
models and we figured
out on average what
bidder preferences were,
and then we predicted not
just how they would bid,
but also how many would
even participate,
in the open ascending auction,
without using any data.
So it's a completely
different game
and actually theory
would just that
actually half as
many small bidders
should show up at
the open ascending auction.
So it's a really different game.
But using just the data
from the seal bit auctions,
we could actually do
the counterfactual prediction
of what would happen in
this very different
auction format
and predict very
successfully there.
So that's most model's economics
would not be able to pass a test
like that and it was
really exciting to be able
to to do those kinds of
counterfactual predictions.
>> So, this idea
of we have models,
we did the model,
some set of assumptions
about the world,
we run them in the world.
We may or may not see
a challenge as they
have or problems they
have from our evidence stream
that we have in place.
We might later find
a bug or a problem,
even when that's
been longstanding,
yet exhaustion as to our models,
and or understanding
of the system,
and then we have to go
back and cycle in and
somehow repair or come up with
new theories to fix that.
I'm curious how
often that happens
in economics these days.
Is it less as we deploy
these systems in
more or less ways
and observe and then
refine them or is
it we still find
funding once in
a while a major gaffe.
Oh! My gosh. That
doesn't work very well.
>> Well, I would
say that models are
the macroeconomy generally
don't work very well.
>> So we're in good shape.
>> We have a long way to go.
It's not the people's fault,
it's just that at some level
to learn something from data.
It's most useful if you have
experimental stimulus
or you can tweak
one part and hold the other
conditions fixed and in
the macroeconomy it's
just very hard to do so.
But in microeconomic settings,
like in this timber
auction setting,
they literally did
an experiment and randomized,
which auctions were
first prize seal bid
and which ones were
open ascending.
So, you really had
that experimental variation and
you could use that
to test the models.
We did try different models
to make sure that we had
ones that did the best job
both in sample,
but also in counterfactual
predictions.
>> They say or it's
just the issue of can we take
this whole experience
and new model to
another domain and see if it
still has the same effects?
>> Well, so you would
build a different model.
So the option models
are very specific.
Everything about it is specific
to that particular game.
So certainly, that literature,
we've been doing empirical
models of auctions since
the 1980s and so
they've gotten better
and better and better.
Broadly, I think the paradigm
has stayed the same,
but we've gotten more flexible
estimation techniques
and we've incorporated
more richness in them.
But you're also limited by
the variation that's in the data.
So another thing
that economics puts
a lot of emphasis on
is causal inference.
Usually, the the main use case of
an empirical economic model
is to do some counterfactual.
You want to understand,
in microeconomics, what was
the effect of the intervention?
What was the effect of raising
the minimum wage What would
happen if I changed my price?
> What would happen if kind of
notions of the counterfactual?
>> Exactly, and so
for many years,
we've had to actually
do heroic things.
So, we've had to figure out
what would happen if
two firms merge and so
a key and a typical
expert witness thing for
an empirical economist would be
to estimate demand for products,
then say what if two firms
merged and they maximize profits,
how much would they raise prices?
So these are all
about worlds that
we've literally
never seen before.
Those models, of course,
are controversial because if
they've never seen before,
when I used to explain these
to computer scientists,
how can you build models when
you can't validate them?
This is crazy. You guys were
really even scientists
if you do that.
Part of the answer is well,
the Department of Justice
has to make a decision,
I'm sorry but I can't have
the firms merge and
then unmerge them.
So I really do need
to make decisions.
But I would say that one of
the themes of my research
which has really
been reinforced by
starting to interact
with computer scientists
is that we should
find ways to validate
our models and yes,
we can't make the firms merge,
but there may be
things in the data.
>> That you can
generalize them somehow.
>> Yes. We can look
at some things.
We're not exactly like that. That
are held out data
that's a little bit
different than the data you
used to estimate and see
how well you do for
those held out situations.
>> Speaking of this,
we've seen rise
of data-centric methods,
their advances in
machine learning,
the ability to predict with
confidence scores
of various kinds.
Comment a little bit
about the rise in
uses of machine learning in
economics and economic modeling.
>> So, this is still fairly
Nietzschean economics,
but I feel like it's on the verge
of exploding and really,
if I had to thank Microsoft for
one and many things I
thank Microsoft for,
one of them is that this is
where I learned about
machine learning,
and I was introduced
to machine learning by
Microsoft Research
researchers who
were working in
the Bing search engine.
So, I think I was
one of the first,
if not the first economist,
leading economist to say,
"Hey, this is really big."
I think that there are things
about machine learning that you
can bring into economics
that would really make
things different.
I should mention that in
our first interactions.
It was this strange thing
where I was an
economist and I said
economics has been using
data to make decisions
and do analysis for
decades and really,
we have never imported
anything from
computer science into doing this.
We're expert witnesses, we
run government agencies,
we work on drugs in school
class size and minimum wages.
Computer science isn't
even part of this conversation.
How come you think
that you actually
have a way to do this better.
Then the computer
scientists were like,
we're running
a whole search engine
like there's no economists here,
we've never learned anything
about econometrics.
How could this possibly
have anything to teach us?
Actually, what's been
really exciting is that
in the last 10 years both sides,
I think, have really
realized that there are
some interesting things to learn.
>> What are some of
the, in your mind,
some of the key touch points or
synthesis opportunities that are
coming to the fore
with computer science,
particularly machine
learning, artificial
intelligence more
broadly in economics?
>> Yeah, so I think economics
has always been good at it.
There are really laser focused on
counterfactual prediction
cause and effect,
what if questions,
but always like in
a small data framework.
So you assume, roughly you have
three covariates and
a million observations.
So, we worked on
flexible models but in
a very small data like
a very small number of
covariates setting.
We pretended that God
gave us our model,
the god of economics gave
us the functional form and
actually data mining was
a pejorative term that
was like what people
did that were cheating.
It was like a synonym
for P-value hacking.
P-value hacking
meaning keep testing
things over and over
again until you
find something that
fits your hypothesis.
So, what I feel
we've really imported very
well from machine learning in
economics is
this data-driven search
for models and
much richer classes
of models and much better
more systematic ways
to fit the data well.
Where I feel that
machine learning was,
there's always been people
in machine learning who thought
about friends people
like Judea Pearl,
but it was really
fairly Nietzsche
and you would meet
machine learning people
who really weren't very
conversant in
the framework of it.
You could finish a PhD
in Computer Science
and mostly think about,
you'd learn mostly
about prediction
and so you would come.
>> Even that even describes
Judea Pearl's left until
1988 or so as I recall.
>> Yeah, but still today
a lot of people come out
and talk come out of a PhD
and they've in some sense,
they've learned about prediction,
about fitting data and then
if you have this hammer
you feel like
everything's a nail.
But if you take something
like trying to do quick
prediction in the search engine.
In fact, we're doing
some counterfactual predictions,
because we're asking
the question,
what would happen if
I took something from
the third position and put
it into the first position.
So, you're actually doing
a what if that changes
the environment away from the one
that you used to fit the data.
I think a lot of the tech firms
will talk about things
as if they are doing
counterfactuals,
but the algorithms themselves
didn't account for that
and they were just fitted.
>> Yeah.
>> It's interesting.
Sorry I chopped up, but
actually you got me excited
here about thinking
about some of my conversations
with you to Pearl directly.
It's been interesting how
passionate he is about
the core capability in
any intelligence system to
be a human with one's we're
trying to build to do
counterfactual reasoning,
to imagine, to envision
possibilities that
don't exist today,
don't exist here and now,
and to imagine manipulations,
actions, sequences of action
that would change the world.
The fact that all civilization
cannot come out of
that capability,
a pop of civilization came from
the special human ability
to do that well.
Yet largely, we see today an AI,
prediction technologies as
well as applied in business,
prediction technologies
and that's been
referred to as the AI
revolution in many places.
You've comment about that?
>> Yes. So, I think
that was really why
I got excited about
working about on AI,
why I thought I had something
to bring to the table.
Because all of my training
was about counterfactuals,
but it was applied to
very simple datasets and
really simple problems
with these huge new data sets
as well as opportunities in
tech firms to intervene and run
lots of experiments
and things like that.
There was a possibility to learn
about cause and effect
in a much grander scale.
So, I want the theoretical
insights from people
like Judea Pearl or
Don Rubin that set
up a framework for
thinking about this.
Those are those theoretical
insights can be
implemented in a much richer way,
when you combine
the computational techniques and
the estimation techniques from
machine learning to do
things like personalization,
and to control for
lots of co-variates,
but still maintaining
the rigorous theoretical focus
on cause and effect.
So, just as an example,
in old style economics
we might have said,
let's look at the average
effective changing price.
Then we might run an experiment
with price changes or it
might be that there's
some natural experiment in
the past something that caused
the price to pay change that was
unrelated to consumer demand,
but we would estimate
an average effect.
Machine learning
has gotten really
good at personalized predictions.
So, you can adapt a lot
of the algorithms from
personalized prediction
or just personalized
fitting, like,
saying okay which of these people
is going to click or which of
these people is going to buy,
and then adapt those techniques
to answer the
question for which of
these people will
a price change cause
them not to buy or
cause them to buy.
So, it's not a huge leap
computationally,
and algorithmically
from one to the other,
but there are also
some key insights
that are important to
recognize when you get there.
So, let me, when
we talk about this
in economics is
we call it identification.
We want to know, if I
had an infinite dataset
could I possibly
answer my question?
For causal questions, if you have
a randomized experiment
that varied the treatment,
then it's pretty clear that I can
learn about cause and effect,
but what if I don't?
There's a lot of question
of work in economics about
what you could do
if you didn't have
an actual randomized experiment.
But there's still
something in the data that
varied that could be used to
find the causal effect anyway,
but it's very delicate
getting that done.
>> How do we deal with these days
in economics with causation
under uncertainty?
We have a problem with
distribution over
a causal effect or
the impact of a cause.
>> So, there are different
branches of dealing with that.
So, in the classical approaches,
we would estimate a model and
there would be a confidence
interval around the effect.
So I would estimate
a price elasticity.
Price elasticity means how
responsive is say a market
to a price change.
Then, I would try to get
an unbiased estimate
of that price elasticity
and put a confidence
interval around it.
A lot of the machine
learning models actually
don't have good statistical
properties and you wouldn't
necessarily be able
to get an estimate of
a parameter out of
those models that
centered on the truth.
So, one of the focuses
of my theoretical
research has been
to provide the
statistical foundation
for popular machine
learning models.
I focused on random forests
because they are amenable to
statistical analysis
and they work pretty
well for a class of problems.
>> As others might
say, you can always do
bootstrap to get
some statistics and
some properties over even models
that don't have the foundational
properties you want.
>> Yeah, exactly. So,
I mean and, of course,
neural nets have eluded a lot
of theoretical analysis.
But actually, for some problems
that are a little bit
simpler like
economic data sets where
you might have [inaudible]
, your curvature,
where we have modified
versions of random forests
that do things like
bias correction or combine
linear models with
the random forest that will do
a pretty good
job fitting data that's
not quite as complex
as like images.
Then, we've provided
the statistical guarantees
so that people can then
get what they want,
a parameter estimate and
a confidence interval.
We also have a tradition of
Bayesian modeling in economics,
which is always been
more niche but that tradition-
>> That's unfortunate.
>> -actually meets very well
with the computer science
tradition, and actually,
the work I'm going
to present today,
it feels is in
the Bayesian tradition.
I'm working with David Bly,
who's a computer
scientist at Columbia.
>> He is a friend?
>> Yeah. He's gotten very
interested in
these Causal Models.
So, Bayesian models are actually
very amenable to
more complex counterfactuals,
because you're generally writing
down a data generating process,
and so that data
generating process in
some sense is a model
of how the world works.
>> Exactly.
>> So, coming back to
your question about AI,
let me elaborate on
that a little bit more.
Economics has
sort of two categories
of counterfactuals
that we might do.
One it's like
there's a treatment,
a minimum wage, or
even a price increase.
Some people in the data
have experienced
that change and
we're just trying to
figure out what would
happen if everybody
experienced the change,
or what was the comparison
between people who had the
change and people who didn't.
But it's always something that's
actually happened in
the world and that's
why the program evaluation
or treatment effect literature.
There's another literature which
tries to be more ambitious,
but also requires
more assumptions.
This is the literature
that would say what
would happen if two firms merged?
What would happen if I raised
a price that has never
been charged before?
So, of course, you have to
have some extrapolation.
If for things like
raising prices though,
maybe the extrapolation
isn't too crazy.
If you could really learn about
consumer preferences from
seeing the choices they
make and you
extrapolate carefully,
you can have a pretty grounded
view of what would
happen if the price
went someplace you've
never seen before.
So, a model.
So, you need more functional
form assumptions for that.
Because if you're just feeding
in a dataset you have,
things can go wildly wrong
without any functional.
If you don't have
any functional form assumptions,
things can go wildly wrong if you
go outside of
the range of the data.
While these sort of
more structured models
that build up and say,
I'm going to estimate for
each consumer based on
their past behavior,
how they feel about prices.
Then I can extrapolate to
a situation where I present
the consumer with another choice.
Similarly, we can model
firm profit functions.
If we can understand
the parameters
of a firm profit function and we
assume they maximize profits,
then I can evaluate
what they would
do in a situation they
haven't been in before.
Or better in an auction,
if I understand
their preferences,
I can understand how they
would play a different game.
>> Thinking of preferences,
in the mid-90s,
I and colleagues worked
on recommender engines,
even Bayesian versions of this.
The idea was, we would assume
static preferences of the users
coming into a service,
for example, and we would
post this for assessment.
Movies, for example.
Like this movie; yes/no, yes/no,
to come up with
a probability distribution
over their preferences and,
of course, items that they
would prefer or choose.
We would use dive
information application.
If we say, here was
the next most valuable item
to assess, to maximum,
we get to the core of
static preferences
without worrying
about causality at
all in those days.
I'm guessing and I know
for certain companies,
this is still the way
recommender systems work.
You might like to buy this book
versus doing
richer causal reasoning.
You could critique the old way
and the assumptions versus
what you do today if you
had unlimited time to
assessed and unlimited
computing data.
>> So, I actually think
that the connections
between what you were talking
about there and what
we're doing today,
I'm promoting today are tight.
I think in some sense like
Bayesian are Bayesian,
whether they are economists
or computer scientists to
some level because you
are writing down
a generative model of the world.
>> Right.
>> That is basically
what economists do.
They write down
generative models of
the world which
impose assumptions.
>> Right.
>> I think if you're going to
extrapolate, you
need assumptions.
I think that's really
a core point for AI.
If you want an AI to work in
the environment you
have, that's awesome.
If you want the AI to do anything
outside of the
environment experienced,
then suddenly you
really need models,
because you need to know how
to extrapolate from
what you've learned.
So, I would say that I think that
recommender literature
is actually great.
You're writing down
a generative model,
you're trying to learn
the parameters of the model.
The things that we might add
in would be thinking harder
about what variation in
the data really allows
you to learn things.
So, if you just had
historical log data
and you were only using
that historical log data,
it could be that the things
that people were
shown in the past
were not accidental.
Somebody was shown
something and they chose
it because of the
characteristics of that person.
>> Probably effect
and the sampling,
basically that model you
set an assumption in
the sampling procedure.
>>Yeah, exactly. Then one
of the things economists
or causal inference people in
statistics might add
in to that is to say,
okay you either needed to
actually only work from
experimental data
where the choices that
people saw were
randomized in some way
to really understand
their preferences,
or if the log data was
generated from a process,
then you need to estimate
aspects of the process that
generated the data to control
for the selection effects,
to control for the fact that
some people picked book A,
but that was because they
were never shown book D.
Another people shown and picked
the book D but they were
never shown the book A.
So, you need to
correct for the fact
that not everybody was shown
the same thing in
making their choices.
But to some extent,
I think in some applications,
you might have been working
with logged data that was
fairly clean and those problems
wouldn't make
that big a difference,
while in other
settings like when I
looked at this in Bing Ads,
these problems are really big.
Number two is with a scientist
that makes up research
for a while and he
was very interested in
these ideas as well
and we work together on
some things and he did
a bunch of additional work
on showing the difference
between experimental estimates.
He basically run experiments
and so you could compare
what you got from
purely experimental data
and from the log data
using the machine learning
methods in practice,
and you could show
and demonstrate
that you got
the wrong answers from
not taking additional steps
to compensate for the fact
that your data is
not experimental.
So, I think we have great
techniques for doing that kind of
compensation in
small data settings.
But I think we still don't
have them at the right scale.
I think there's still
room for improvement and
big recommendation systems
today because we haven't
figured out how to fully
and optimally scale
those techniques to
production size problems.
The big change. Just to pave
it a bit on to careers,
she seem to be very excited
about things you're doing.
You love these ideas,
and you've made a set of
career decisions over time,
to bring you to this place.
Of course for every person,
we are all different and,
we can do what is of course
for their own lives,
and imagine what we might be.
But you've got into
a really fabulous place.
I think from
the outside looking in.
I'm curious if you have
some career advice
for others right now,
as they do their
what is out there,
the viewers watching this,
they're thinking about careers,
even in economics, or computer
science or related fields.
>> Sure. So, I would say
the first 12 years in
my career were very successful,
but I was working in
a very mature field.
So, I told some of
the timber auction work
I talked about it was
beautifully executed.
It laid some good role models for
other people to think about
validating the structural
models and so.
But ultimately, I would say
none of it was actually
path-breaking.
Because the all the fields
that I was working in,
had the paradigms were
established when I was
born as an economist.
I was always jealous
during that time period
of the people in the really
the 1980s had laid
the groundwork.
The real conceptual
insights came in
the 80s before I was
born as an economist.
We could extend them and
expand them and improve them.
But it wasn't didn't
really feel fundamental.
So, actually when I got
the call to come
work for Microsoft,
I got a call said,
"Do you want to
come meet with Steve Ballmer?"
I said sure, and then he was
like "Yeah I think we need
an economist to think
about this online stuff."
I was like "Okay sure".
>> This online stuff.
>> Yeah. They're we're pretty
good at Windows, I
know how to do that.
I don't think we really
understand how to
compete with Google.
That was a crazy thing
for me to do.
I was a professor at Harvard.
I was I had just
gotten this big prize.
Everybody loved what
I had done to date.
It was I should have just kept
going in what I was doing.
>> You said big prize,
but this is like
the Nobel Prize in Economics
for a young economist.
>> Yes it was, that's
actually how Steve
found out about me.
There was a big article
about me in the paper.
So, the natural thing
to do would've been to
just be great at
what I was great at.
I really, I was working,
at that point to find
the field as market design,
which was bringing theory
and data together to solve
auction problems and
school choice problems
and things like that.
I was well-recognized
as the young
not the old leader but
at least the leader
of my generation,
a leader of
my generation in that.
But then the opportunity
came to come to Microsoft,
and I just, was just,
seduced by this idea of,
I went in and I looked
at the search engine,
and it was just wide open.
I realized right away,
that my economic tools were
not up to the task actually.
This was harder and broader
and more complicated.
But at the same time,
I had the instinct that there
really was economics here
and there was value to add.
So, I felt like from
the business perspective,
there were all these amazingly
brilliant engineers,
but they didn't know
about advertisers,
or prices, or auctions,
or things like that.
But also, I learned
that they weren't as
familiar with causality and
that was also very important for
thinking about what would
happen if we changed our auction?
What would happen if
the prices changed?
What would happen if we
introduced this new product?
So, there was a lot of
contribution from
the data side as well.
So, I think what, from
the advice perspective,
I would say that,
I think what I correctly saw,
was it here was something
that was wide open.
It was Greenfield.
The conceptual fame.
Yes I was building
on the shoulders of
giants at some level,
but I could actually help
lay some foundations.
But I also, in some sense
had to take a big risk,
because for a while first of all,
I was just very busy trying to
do this business work
with Microsoft,
and build stuff, and learn stuff,
and I didn't know SQL
and I had coded in
C but not in
all these other languages
that were being
used in production.
>> But you had good
experiences as
an administration person
for a Unix system.
>> I had a CS degree.
But when I did it,
we learn PROLOG and LISP
and all these other stuff,
so it wasn't
very relevant CS degree.
But I had to and I
didn't know anything
about machine learning.
I didn't know the jargon there.
So, I had to learn
until there was a bit
of a lull in my CV,
because I was working
building stuff and because I had
to learn all these
new disciplines.
But I think that was,
and then also a lot
of the economists
were telling me I was crazy.
This big data stuff.
That's just description.
That's not economics.
Machine learning that's just
fitting, that's not for us.
So, there was a lot of
pretty aggressive
negative feedback
from my colleagues as well.
But I saw this and I was just so
sure that there was
something there,
and I was also sure that
it makes a big difference
to be a leader,
if you get there first
and you're smart,
and you're humble and
learn, you can be a leader.
It was very likely,
I could be a leader
here in a way that I
hadn't been before.
There's a difference
between getting tenure,
and getting prizes, and actually
really being a leader
and defining a field.
So, this was
my chance to do that.
I took the chance
and it paid off,
and I'm excited about that.
But it also, it did
require being humble,
going out to a computer science
conference and be like,
"Who the hell are you?"
There was all the stuff
I didn't know.
There's a lot of stuff
I still don't know.
So, it required taking
a lot of risks.
But I brought the things that
there's these two takeaways.
One is, find something
that's young,
where you can make a difference.
Then the second thing
though is to be
a little bit differentiated.
Because in some sense, if I
was just one in a sea of,
If I just completely
tried to be a machine
learning person,
why would I be the best one.
But I found a niche,
where I knew I had something
to bring to the table.
Special expertise.
Then, there's more of an ability
to make a contribution.
So, maybe for
the young people today,
there's a little sense of,
there are somethings
that are getting maybe a
little overdone, in AI.
So, you want to be
a little bit ahead of
the game rather than
behind the game.
I would say, at some level
this pure prediction
problem is just
going to be commoditized
to some extent.
We're going to get
self-tuning neural nets
and AI's will tune
the neural nets.
>> Giving all of our secrets now.
>> That part will be
more commoditized.
But then, there's still
a conceptual part
of really understanding how
it works, and why it works.
Which was foundational to
figuring out what
the next breakthrough is.
So, I guess I would suggest that
the tide is going to turn back
to a little bit
more conceptual insight,
and if we really want to
get to human-like learning,
there actually is a sense in
which just fitting is
going to hit a wall.
So, we're going to
have to bring back,
combine that with some modeling.
Because it's just
a fact that you can't
extrapolate without a model.
>> What do you think
some big feasible surprises
in the field of economics will
be over the next 15 years?
What things might happen even if
it describe in
a little bit more of
abstractly that would be,
almost surprising from
today's point of view,
that will rely heavily on
economic inferences and models,
and their use in the world.
>> Well, I think at some level
there's different parts
of economics.
So, I think in some level,
the economic ideas
may not change.
If I see something where
the data is going to come in,
it's going to be the personalization
changes or insights.
There's a whole bunch of
some findings right now.
That stuff doesn't work.
We go out and evaluate
training programs,
and they do a little bit but
they don't work that much.
But, the typical of
economic measurement
of a government project
or something like that
is that it doesn't work.
But a lot of these things.
>> The actual model
doesn't work or the
government program doesn't work?
>> The program doesn't
work. So, there's a lot of-
>> Or both.
>> There's a lot of negativity.
Things like educational
interventions don't work,
health interventions don't work.
But I think that what we've
learned from tech companies,
is that you shouldn't think
about coming up with
one grand idea,
and then go out and spend
a year testing that one idea.
But rather you
iteratively improve.
>> Run flights.
>> Run flights but lots of them
and you incrementally improve.
So, I believe, that
the economist is going to
become much more of an engineer,
because the some of
these economic problems like
retraining the workforce,
finding government
programs that work,
are going to be recast
as digital programs.
Digital programs are amenable
to incremental innovation.
So, we will join up
with the engineers,
and come up with methods
to incrementally improve.
So, where that meets
the current machine
learning literature
in bandit's, contextual bandit's,
reinforcement learning,
and that side of AI,
which has always
actually had a bit of
a causal bent to it.
Because you're trying to
understand what works.
What treatment to give.
So, that's going
to come together.
So, my prediction is that
economists are going to
become more engineers,
and instead of complaining
that nothing works,
we're going to start
building things
that do work to achieve
economic outcomes,
to make governments
more efficient.
But economists ranges
on resource allocation.
So, we're going to do that on
resource allocation problems,
pricing problems.
So, we're going to both
figure out what works,
we're going to
realize that nothing
works if it's one-size-fits-all.
But there are a lot
of things work if
they're actually personalized and
appropriately delivered with
the correct information.
>> Even imagine someday a
congressional hearing about how
much to explore versus exploit
in a program be fabulous.
>> Well, I think that's
actually not so crazy.
When I teach to
business leaders and boards
of directors and talk about AI,
and actually what they
need to do at some level
the high-level leaders
of a firm to
figure out how to
regulate the AI.
They need to figure out
what guidelines
should I be setting.
What makes it safe. How
do I make sure it's good.
Governments have the same role,
the banking regulators
have to figure out
how do the AI that
are used in banks,
what makes it safe,
what makes it fair.
So, this broader view
of regulating
and setting the objectives
for AI, is hugely impactful.
So, that's partly why
you might have asked
in my previous answer,
why would economists have
anything to do with this.
But actually when the AI is
solving an economic problem,
and it's living in
a real world setting,
what it optimizes?
What are the measures?
How do you judge success.
What constraints
do you put on it?
Is it a decision support tool?
Or does it actually
make the decision.
All of those.
>> Whose values.
>> Whose values are represented.
All of this stuff,
really becomes- you don't
decompose the problems,
it becomes an integrated problem
and that's why I feel like
these interdisciplinary
teams will
work together to create this,
but I feel like we're
actually going to
do a lot of good in the world.
>> On that note. Thanks
very much, Susan.
>> Thank you.